vambora vambora ray aí vamos ver vamos
ver vamos ver vamos ver vamos nessa
se alguém falar que esse lugar não tem
muito a ver com o que o rap tem feito
vou falar ah ah a iaa a bora bora bora
ei eu gosto é livre ninguém me cancela
tipo mandela saindo da sala mas minha
boa do cheia de herói da todas cabeça
quando janela partiu para o baile fugiu
da balela batendo os sabores eles panela
roubamos a cena no teca liberte as but
the head que mussarela quente que nem a
chapinha do crespo tão presos estão se
armando faço questão de votar no meu
texto que pretas e pretos estão se
amando quente que nem o conhaque no cope
sim pro santo tombou derrubando aquele
orgulho que já foi roubada de bola de
meia foi recuperando vários homens-bomba
pela quebrada tentando ser certo na
linha errada abateu sobre a bomba com
granadas e têm permissão está mudando da
radar seu rebento ruim na rua no hotel
dança nenhuma fica mais fácil
fazer esta dor falou sobre a corda é
porque foi uma raiz africana exame a
essa ponta de lança umbabarauma de jeito
eu perceba falando aqui esse é o tipo
macumba espero que os uma música preta a
gente assina funk é filha do que duas
uma com a sua trilha de quem vai dar 2 e
também faz a trilha de quem vai da roma
eu não faço o tipo de gerar e nem uso
máscara e silos honro música da equipa
não quer debitar quando nego que quero o
torrão o nego que gosta de ouro no porto
leva desaforo neste filme eu sou o vilão
300 rodrigo autor eu enfrento coragem eu
tomo um elemento nas ruas e só amor
restaurante bares e motéis é por esses
lugares que como os anjos e demônios me
falam do amor renan gerando logo nós
como a perdição as obras ao a rua me
serve tipo moldamos tornando olímpica de
errado quando o pai o rei não é presley
é um mandato bem na grota sapatão tom
mais leiam bonita ligado fez o padrão é
branco erradiquem roma soma um produto
premium lesar tipo jequiti tipo mary kay
como reconhecer eu aparecer pra mim
aparecer vão oferecer uma enzima quente
como renê se para ficar mais claro
escurecer aquele passado não esquecer
vou cantar aos estima que nesse às vezes
eu acerto às vezes falha que é trabalho
ao amanhecer e à noite é preta e
maravilhosa no pitlane hangu perto do
fogo que nem o coro de tamboril barrada
de joão do rio nesse sufoco estudando
socorre nela golã dando a vida é um
filme meu deus aqui nem garante novo
tipo de xangô atores e confusões curvas
enquanto sóis fazendo minha mala do pic
cigano do sempre mudado de corações
luzes decorações sorriso amarelo nas
ilusões os preto a chave
abram os portões aí
[Música]
ai ai ai ai vamos pará pará banpará sala
são paulo
oi salve
muito obrigado a todos valeu o convite
'tamo junto' victoza pensa conhecido
também como manequim com do certo ou uaw
valeu só força e segue o baile